hello and welcome to my presentation on
addressing open source model sharing
challenges for scikit-learn and how to
tackle them
I'm Marvin I work at hugging face and
I'm one of the core developers of SK Ops
this library that we are developing
so
when it comes to open source ml there
are several challenges uh to sharing
models one of them is security as you
might know uh pickle is not that secure
it might execute arbitrary code on your
local machine
and uh it's it's normalized it's not
built for machine learning but rather
for python in general and uh for by
means of reproducibility we mean uh the
represent reproducibility of a model so
uh assume that you have a model and you
want to get the same model so you
actually need to version a model with
um its own documentation and some code
for reproducibility
and you might not see it in the internet
especially some of the papers are
lacking too much reproducibility and the
checkpoints are not shared online
and it would be nice if models were
actually hosted publicly with an
inter-interactive playground uh so that
you don't you could know what amount
what a given model does without actually
download trying to download and
and using it
and for this we are currently developing
scaleops or Scopes you can call it
however you want we try to address these
problems
and firstly we try to tackle secure
serialization with a new serialization
format specifically developed for
scikit-learn
secondly the version models with model
carts that you can programmatically feel
and they help they they help us document
the models and tour this integration
with hugging face Hub where all of these
myths and you can try the model without
running on your local
and I will go through how you can
interact with API later but I just want
to
um I just want to say that like uh this
presentation is set according to how a
typical
workflow with SK Ops works
um firstly after your training is done
uh you create a local repost story on
your machine
and this repository once in initiated it
contains a model config a model card and
the model that you have saved in and I
will show you how to create that
um but why do we have so many files so
model card is essentially for a
producibility and model documentation uh
the configuration file contains features
a sample from the data set Library
versions used to train the model and the
tasks that you're trying to solve and
this is used in firstly the inference
widget that I'm going to show you later
on that you can go to our models
repository online and just try the model
and the inference API which Powers this
widget and also you can send the request
to this inference API without
downloading and using the model which is
which is just better than
downloading it and then
um
it's really good for anyone who would
like to try your model and see what it
does before using it for their own use
case if they want to do that
and
the to get started with the local
repositor you can easily save the model
you can save you can save it with Picola
as well but you can also save it skops
format that I will go through later on
and then initialize the Repository
uh you will pass the requirements again
the task that you are trying to solve it
can be tabular classification tabular
regression text classification it can be
anything
uh to the path to the directory the
repository will be created in
uh your futures and the path where the
model is saved and and then it will
create this
um it will have these repository it will
create this repository save the model
inside
uh create a configuration file that is a
Json and that's it
and we are currently working on
initializing the model card
automatically because uh some
information in this configuration can be
used to also create the model card
and what does this Json contain it's it
contains column names requirements a
piece of your
features like piece of your training
data that people can actually see and
you know like see that maybe they can
use the model
uh the name of the model files and the
task that you are trying to solve and
this is later on used for the influence
API as I have
said
and what is a model card so
Mobile card is essentially a readme
markdown file but
um we have a separate class for it so
that you can programmatically create
that
and it's a documentation that contains
information about your model
it can contain anything including a
description of your model description of
the data set limitations about the model
inform metrics tables plots and more you
can add all of these
um just programmatically
and by default when you initialize the
model card
which I will show you on the next slide
for the API a hyper parameter table is
written to this model card the plot of
the model like an interactive HTML plot
of the pipeline or model if you are
saving a model is safe there and also
a snippet to use the model so that
people can actually know how to infer
with your model is saved
and um as I said you can
programmatically create the model cars
and add information and this card object
is later rendered uh to a markdown file
during the save
the sections to be filled are previously
defined with a ginger template
you can just change that like we have a
defaults templates that you can see in
this tutorial but you can just Define
your own template and just use whatever
you want
and once you create that Ginger template
you can inject any value
as like in this um in this code snippet
by calling add on the mobile card
and you can also add tables plots
metrics and more like if so long as if
it's an image file like you can save any
plot that you created with netplotlib or
Graphics or whatever you can just save
them uh metrics are later turned into a
markdown table and the tables are we use
tablets to create them
and for the API there are sections
specific methods uh uh and we have we
have ad plots that you can pass the plot
name the plot path and add multiple
plots at once and the same goes for
adding metrics and tables
and this this is one of the sections
that is automatically created for you
this is an interactive HTML plot that
includes the components of the pipeline
and toggles open for
um various parameters that the component
has and this plot breaks unfortunately
the readability of the model card if you
are opening the raw MD file
without seeing it to run markdown reader
so there is an option to actually turn
it off as well
and another one is marked hyper
parameter table of the model is
automatically generated and written to
markdown table
which is cool for versioning your model
and for the serialization this is an
experimental feature
and we welcome the feedbacks uh that
would be nice if you could try and let
us know uh how it goes
and this um this model format is
essentially a zip file that contains
parameters as bytes and model related
attributes as Json
we don't use reduce that pickle users
and we avoid pickle
and all this feature as of now is
released and the format supports native
scikit-learn sci-fi math numpy objects
to be serialized and I will explain more
about this feature during the uh
while I'm explaining the API because
that makes more sense
so you can simply dump the model by
passing the model and the path to dump
and the tricky part is about the loading
the model so the the responsibility of
loading a model and trusting the
components is in user's hands
so you pass the model path and The
Trusted parameter
and distrusted can be a Boolean either
true or false
and it can be a list of The Trusted
types which we can retrieve
you can
as of what as for what is trusted
anything that is by default existing
within Pi data stack like sci-fi
scikit-learn
math anything is trusted you can have
custom Transformers and function
Transformers in psychic learn
and so long as they contain functions
from math sci-fi and more they will be
trusted however if you have custom code
it will not be serialized and in here I
have a pipeline with a divide column
custom Transformer from scikit-learn uh
and a pipeline and the decision tree
regressor this currently seem to be
untrusted but we will soon include them
in trusted you can load you cannot load
um without passing your value to trusted
and this puts responsibility on the user
to trust this file or not so you can
either pass through meaning that you
trust this file and what it contains or
you can pass the the types that this
list of types that this file contains
you cannot also pass something like let
me not get this divide column custom
Transformer and let me get this as you
can you can also do that this will fail
and
lastly for integration with hugging face
Hub uh you might not know about hacking
face Hub so I will explain a bit
so hugging face Hub contains you might
also know hugging face with only
Transformers but we host every Library
we have model repositories data set
repositories and something that we call
spaces which contains applications that
are made with stream knit gradio or
JavaScript whatever you want we hosted
and we have model our model repositories
are essentially hosted with hugging face
Hub and this is done through Hub utils
module
and I wanted to check if there is any
problem okay there is not
uh once your local repository to pushed
and is pushed and is public so you can
also set this
um repository on hacking face Hub to be
private as well anyone can try your
model in a widget or through sending a
request without downloading the model
but we also wrap this in a function and
I will show that and the markdown is
automatically read on HUB does make it
easier to read so you can have anything
that is marked down and it will be
nicely put over there
so uh while calling push you you could
just give repo Story ID and path to
local repository to push your model to
hiking face hub
and this is the hosted inference API
that is powered by something we call
inference API it's about sending
requests to an API to in to infer with
the model wherever there is like a data
section and like it contains whatever
you want to infer from the model
and this is the main reason why we have
a lot of content on config so as you can
see here firstly
the fact that the Tabler
um tabular
models do not have Universal features
like images have pixels or
um the text have words or like audio has
signals like it's it's it's
unfortunately not a uh it doesn't
contain a universal feature so you
actually need to define the columns and
the possible things it can contain the
data types of those
columns in order to infer with them so
in the config that's why we have columns
the example data and the tasks that
you're trying to solve so that this
hosted inference API is actually
constructed with a table for instance if
you have a table of regression this will
return a this will have like a table
format you can input your things with
and then it will return a number
which is very cool
and we have wrapped this this whole
sending a request process with the get
model output
so you can infer with the model without
downloading it by calling getmodel
output with your model ID and the data
you want to infer
and with this you don't necessarily need
to do inference
um you need to do inference by
downloading the model
and lastly great for graduate
integration so basically uh radio is a
library that you need to that you can
use in order to build demos to your
machine learning models or
um the or
um data applications and we grade your
recently introduced uh at like the
tabular components
to have better data science related
workflows rather than unstructured
machine learning workflows and we have
developed a gradual integration that is
powered by this inference API so like
you have two lines of code
and
just a second I did I not put that
so I'm sorry uh apparently I didn't put
it but basically what you do is you load
an interface with only one one line of
code I can write this into the chat
later on and it will load uh the the
this interface so basically what's
happening is that
graduate infers what this model takes
and outputs from thanks to the hub
integration so basically it knows that
it's a tabular regression or tabular
classification model so it says hey I
need to have a table as input and a
table as output for batch inference and
it also has an example uh input section
that we previously had with the
inference API as well so that it gives a
hint to the user this title and this
description is not
um is not loaded from the interface and
for fortunately it's something we can
customize later on but the rest of the
interface is actually loaded with one
line of code and I think it's pretty
good because like as a data professional
you don't necessarily need to
spend a lot of time on
um creating demos for your for your
applications that you will only use to a
client or a stakeholder of your project
and you need to focus on your data or
like you need to focus on your model
instead
so that's why this is developed so
basically if you have a SK Ops model
serialized with SK Ops and if you have
if you are hosting it on hugging face
Hub then you can directly load this
interface uh into wherever you want you
can also host it openly thanks to
hugging face spaces as I mentioned it's
uh it's it's the type of repository
where you are hosting streamlit or radio
or JavaScript or whatever you want based
data or machine learning applications
yes
and lastly
if you have if you want to learn more
about this we appreciate so you can
check our documentation
you can contribute uh we currently like
the the code base is not that big at
this point so it's a nice place to
contribute I would say
there are a bunch of open issues you can
also open issues and we appreciate this
more than anything because as I said the
secure serialization is still
experimental and we would like someone
else to break it and just tell us you
know what can be improved
and you can check out the psychic learn
organization page on hugging face Hub
because we feel that with Scopes
examples and cool radio demos of psychic
learning examples and more
and yeah like if you want to read about
the radio integration you can also check
that link
so and my talk is over so I can accept
questions so Valerio hello
Valerio said if it's okay I can answer
okay um thank you thank you very much
um I want to remember that you said you
want to write a line of code
uh yeah I'm going to yeah yeah yeah I'm
going to write it but I would like to
answer a couple of questions first
so
um so is it possible to deploy uh this
application uh outside of hugging face
yes you can deploy it wherever you want
it's essentially like you can deploy it
on your local and there is a parameter
called share when you are launching this
let me send you a code snippet just a
second
and it's essentially Opel NG Rock Tunnel
and it's served for I think seven to two
hours thanks to gradio like you don't
necessarily even need to shut down your
computer like it's served uh it also
runs in collab it runs in many places
you can even embed this
like you can what's like the best part
of using it in spaces is that if you if
you'd hosted the spaces then you can
embed this to your blog posts like you
can have interactive blog posts which is
very cool I think but you can have it
wherever you want because like radio is
open sourced and it wasn't essentially
developed for uh hugging face in general
um I'm going to send documentation of
gradio just a second
and later uh as chaops integration I'm
going to send this to the backstage if
it's okay because I cannot post
and grade your escape's integration just
a second it's here
my computer was lagging a little
so it's just one line of code I'm going
to send this again to again privately
and you can
see
you don't need to do debugging part
sorry but if you want to share this with
someone while serving on your local you
can set share equals true can you send
last last Singapore that I posted and I
saw two questions
um
what data format SK of support when
integrating with hugging face inference
API So currently because this
serialization feature was launched in
the main in in
um was was re launched with the recent
release it wasn't a mainstream thing it
was being developed for a long while
currently inference API only supports
pickle but we will integrate the SK Ops
format very soon
and is the model card intended for a
single instance of a model or a general
model class it's intended for a single
instance of a model in like because it
contains
um specific model specific things like
hyper parameters or you know the
pre-processing stuff that you have used
so it's actually makes sense because you
can version your experiments using this
library and it's lightweight compared to
other versioning libraries I would say
and um
let me see
so in the last snippet I have posted you
can just call that so basically what
you're doing is
I'm going to show that slide so this
is uh this this interface has been
constructed by calling the last uh
snippet so what I'm doing is I call
um the psychic learn slash double
tabular playground model from hugging
face Hub so I need to prepend it by
hugging face so that it knows that it
has to be called from that place
and I am passing a title which is the
super soccer defective product
prediction one and I can pass a
description and then I call launch
and this will be launched and if you
share if you said share it goes true you
can just uh create a host that people
can drive it
and if you if you want you can host it
in spaces and then you know embed that
space to your website to
um to um
I don't know like blog are you this also
runs for 72 hours in one notebook
instance which is very cool like if you
have a Jupiter notebook or collab or
whatever you can just call it from there
yeah
I think there is no other questions do
check out radio it's a very cool uh API
I would say
it makes things very easy